the cops are now in joe's mom's room  looking for somebody just just making  sure there's nobody else in there i'm  like oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my  god  and i hear the jurassic park  on the linoleum floor in the bathroom  and i'm just in the closet and i i  dropped it so i closed my eyes and just  was holding my breath  and the full opens the closet door right  here  what the [ __ ] marty  [Laughter]  you had that waiting [ __ ]  they didn't do that to me  what's wrong with you  oh that was good  that was  scary  i don't know if you should do that one  that was a little bit  [ __ ] handsome oh that's great that's  been on the soundboard for a minute  waiting for the right moment well okay  then that's right and now i'm happy  because that was a perfect [ __ ]  opens the closet door i go  [Music]